The problem that we'll use for this lesson was one that was suggested by one of
our students for the make practice for unit two. And this is the one that we'll
use and it was a problem that was suggested by Matias Wexen from Sweden, as a
practice problem for unit two. And here's how he stated the problem. This is
days old number two and it says given your birthday and the current dates,
calculate you age in days. You have to beware about leap days. Dates are
complicated things. And you can assume that the inputs are correct dates. And
then, there's an example here to say that, well, if you were born on January 1,
2012, and the date today is January 2, 2012, you're 1 day old. So, this is a
great practice problem. Thanks, Matias for suggesting it. And it's generated
lots of discussion on the forums. So, I wanted to step through how I would solve
this problem. If you have not tried it yourself, I would strongly encourage you
to do so. There's a link to the problem in the additional homework to try it
yourself. And I'd suggest keeping notes on how you solve it. Whether you're able
to solve it or not, I hope you'll come back and watch the rest of this lesson.
If you got stuck, this lesson will give you some ideas of how to get unstuck.
And then, when you get unstuck, go back to trying to solve it on your own before
continuing with the lesson. If you were able to solve it yourself, that's great.
This is quite a challenging problem. But I hope you'll still come back to see
how I solve it. I think you'll, perhaps, learn some things from the way I would
approach it and probably I can learn some things from the way you approached it.
So, I hope you'll post on the forum about how you approached it that was
different.